dr. Michael Polyakov is vice president
of policy for the American Council of
trustees and alumni dr. Polyakov
received his BA from Yale University
studied at Oxford University as a Rhodes
Scholar and received his PhD at the
University of Michigan he served
previously as Pennsylvania deputy
secretary for post secondary and higher
education director of education programs
at the National Endowment for the
Humanities and vice president for
academic affairs and research at the
University of Colorado he is the
recipient of the American philology coal
associations excellence in Teaching
Award and the Pennsylvania Department of
Education distinguished service to
Education Award a former professor of
classical literature in ancient history
at Hillsdale College dr. Polyakov is the
author of combat sports in the ancient
world competition violence and culture
please join me in welcoming dr. Michael
Polyakov
thank you for that kind introduction
it's wonderful to see everyone here it's
a real joy to be back at Hillsdale back
again after even more years than
Odysseus was away from his homeland in
Ithaca I get to see admired colleagues
again whom I missed and get to see a
flourishing classics department which I
was once a part and allow me for a
moment to recall some beloved friends
Hillsdale friends who are no longer with
us Bert Fink
Ralph von Sydow ray Penn's L Alex Thomas
John reased
I feel blessed to have known these fine
colleagues fine scholars fine friends
so before I start sniffling let me get
on to the work that we're here to do
well the world of today's collegiate
sports is not always a pretty place it's
plagued by scandal corruption low
academic standards and often
unimaginable expenses it is refreshing
but not surprising that Hillsdale has
gotten right to the question that
matters what does sport have to do with
character
it also doesn't surprise me that
Hillsdale would want to address this
question by looking at its historical
roots its greco-roman roots cicero
warned us that not to know what happened
before you were born is to be a child
forever and to look at our sports and
games which are sometimes indeed quite
childish things when I became a man I
put away childish things something this
is Hillsdale somebody tell me where
that's from
thank you I knew that would happen here
at Hillsdale to look at our sports in
light of the past is doubly important
we're going to address a quintessential
Hillsdale question who do we really want
to be our journey back in time is not
going to be for idle sightseeing we're
going to try to learn something about
ourselves along the way
which is the most valid reason for
studying the ancient world we now enter
the stadium at Ancient Olympia using the
very tunnel through which the athletes
entered they were roaring enthusiastic
crowds but they were hot thirsty and
uncomfortable crowds except for a
handful of dignitaries the spectators
sat on earth and banks there was no
shade the water supply was limited and
of very poor quality you weren't gonna
find that ice-cold jumbo juice at the
refreshment stand
it was midsummer in southern Greece it
was hot as the blazes the Olympics were
all about competition in the extreme not
the voyeurism of comfy spectators the
spectators knew what these contests were
about since most of them would have had
the experience of sport in their local
police dry gymnasia and small festivals
tough sport up close and personal now
that we're in the ancient stadium we're
going to recreate an event from the 54th
Olympiad
this was possibly the most interesting
assignment I had in my whole career as a
classicist to train a group of athletes
to recreate the ancient games for a PBS
BBC documentary that aired before the
2004 Olympics it is the Year 564 BCE
something's missing here
well okay hold on a moment let's see
what happened here there we are a Ricky
on a two-time Olympic victor in the pan
Crotty on a contest not at all
dissimilar from the mixed martial arts
of today is fighting in the final
contest for his third Olympic victory
Ted I think we're having a little
problem here
there we go sorry a richens opponent has
caught him in a standing body scissor
and has thrown his forearm against Eric
Ian's throat choking him Eric Yun is
losing consciousness asphyxiating from
the combined effects of blunt trauma to
the throat and strangulation according
to one action account his trainer
shouted to him from the edge of the area
of competition Erika Yohn what a noble
inscription on your tombstone three
times undefeated at Olympia and with
that a Riki on losing consciousness
caught his opponents ankle in the crook
of his knee let's see if the laser
pointer works and falling to the ground
popped the ankle out of joint his
opponent in agony signal to the referee
I give up not knowing that under him was
the corpse of Eric Young well we don't
know the name of the loser that doesn't
come down to us in history but we do
know that the judges at Olympia
reverently crowned the corpse of a Ricky
on indeed three times Viktor at Olympia
I have to just pause here for a moment I
had reconstructed what I assumed had
happened in this event on the basis of
Greek text and I got these two gentlemen
wonderful mixed martial arts people from
a club in South Africa a Catherine
position and as I was kind of holding
them steady I said to the fellow
underneath playing a Rickie on I want
you very slowly to strength to
straighten your leg against his ankle
and he said to me in his gorgeous South
African accent oh no man I won't do that
it's going to break his ankle and I
began actually a shake to know that the
text that came down to us it described
exactly what happened so here's the
question are these the Greeks that we
know and love from Western civilization
and I'm going to argue yes very much so
indeed
with few exceptions I want to give you
five points for those of you who have to
write a little essay about this take
note now this is going to probably show
up and be useful five points
with few exceptions at the major
athletic festivals recognition and
prizes went only to the victor second
place brought neither glory nor reward
to the best of my knowledge the single
elimination tournament that we use today
was an invention of the ancient Greeks
with few exceptions all competitions
were for individual athletes there was
little interest at all in team games so
don't go looking for the Athenian squash
team or the Spartan soccer team or
anything like that those things really
didn't exist Oh point three athletic
competition was held in deadly earnest
with high stakes of personal honor and
material reward there was almost a
willful disregard for the safety of the
competitors and no quarter was given in
contest forget about all that grant land
rights tougher when the graph one great
scorer comes to write against your name
it matters not who won or lost but how
you played the game that would have had
the Greeks for the most part laughing
and with rather scornful laughter as
well fourth point athletic competition
was open to all social classes but with
few exceptions only two males and fifth
point early in its history perhaps as
early as the 8th century BCE athletes
began to compete completely naked now a
little side story that I have to share
with you you notice that these guys are
not wearing very much they're wearing if
you look closely some little flesh
covered trunks and we have to film this
twice BBC wanted them in g-strings and
that was ok but um PBS was just
recovering from the Janet Jackson affair
and so PBS said that got it we wearing
more than that so on
the filmmaker was not amused that we
to shoot every scene twice it was a
South African and at one point he
shouted out now put on those little
knickers for the damned Americans and I
finally said to me look if you don't
stop that I'm gonna take my clothes off
so let's let's just get on with what we
have to do here so let's get back to the
basic question on his second place
really a disgrace unworthy of memory or
record for a serious athlete as red
Sanders and later Vince Lombardi said
winning isn't everything it's the only
thing but more seriously at the end of
the day we're not as obsessed as we're
the ancient Greeks in valuing only one
place at the top most of us would be
rather proud to come home with a silver
medal from the Olympics or even a bronze
medal or even to have competed in the
Olympics so we have to answer the
question why did the Greeks regard being
runner-up at arguably the greatest
contest that the world has ever known
why did they see this as a disgrace
why was the focus only on individual
contests with so little interest in
being part of a winning team and more
questions why was the level of violence
and danger tolerated and even encouraged
the violence danger and trauma were not
contingencies they were part of the
structure of the sports of ancient
Greece contests were held in the Blazing
Sun and there were no time limits for
the contests no rounds no rest periods
sunstroke we know from ancient sources
was an ever-present danger this goes
even beyond cage fighting let's be
realistic here and consider to the
development of boxing equipment the
Greek boxers in the earliest period you
can kind of barely see that at the top
were light oxide thongs these did
nothing to protect the opponent's face
but by supporting the wrists and
protecting the knuckles they encouraged
even more decisive and last sort of
blows
a boxer's victory is gained in blood
began one inscription honoring a
successful pugilist and Greek art if you
can see closely it's pretty honest about
the effects of the sport blood pouring
from the nose of the athletes this was
by the way Athenian tableware so
obviously nobody was too squeamish about
seeing these things but by the later
part of the fourth century those light
thongs were deemed insufficient and the
Greeks began to box with a heavy Ridge
of leather about an inch and a half
projecting above the knuckles that's got
another view of that these thongs would
inflict staggering injury as you can see
from the face of the boxer who was
wearing those thongs why was that we
know from plato's laws that the Greeks
knew how to make and used padded gloves
in practice much like the boxing gloves
that are familiar to us today now Plato
explained that these gloves would
encourage people in practice to box more
vigorously because they wouldn't be so
afraid of being hurt but the Greeks
never used these padded gloves in
competition it wasn't also the kind of
wrestling that was familiar to us today
we hear of a wrestler winning at Olympia
twice with a most remarkable technique
grabbing and breaking his opponents
fingers so this is a different vision of
sport the story of a Rick Ian with which
we began our journey to the ancient
world was not a unique instance of an
athlete opting for death over defeat
this inscription found at Olympia about
50 years ago one should never think that
our knowledge of antiquity is static
we're getting new evidence all the time
this inscription strongly suggests that
the decision to choose death over defeat
would typically be viewed as appropriate
not tragically foolish the inscription
reads I'll translate for you Agatha's
diamond also called the camel from
Alexandria who had won the Nemean game
she was a
pretty considerable athlete he died here
boxing in the stadium having prayed to
Zeus for victory or defeat age 35
farewell there's no embarrassment
there's no regret about his choice we
find other confirmations of this die of
Chrysostom wrote you know that the
Olympic crown is made of olive but many
have valued above life Tiberius Claudius
Rufus in the second century of our era
and the inscription found at Olympia it
says that he he believed it was better
to score in life than to lose the hope
of a crown so I put two texts here
together one the on your right the
agatha's diamond inscription the other
an imaginary epitaph that sportswriter
from the Boston Globe
Lee Montville wrote for the Korean boxer
kou Kim who died of a brain hemorrhage
after his boxing match with ray Mancini
and as you read he gave His life to
provide some entertainment on a dull
Saturday afternoon in November that was
Lamont Phil's ironic view of what this
man lost now today at least officially
we view death in sport as a tragic
accident not a consummation to be
celebrated on the other hand and here's
our hypocrisy check we're willing enough
to tolerate a significant casualty rate
in our sports whether that's chronic
traumatic encephalopathy or in Bach
modern boxing where we average about 10
deaths per year and that's just among
legal fights that get recorded so
placeholder I want to get back to this
ethical question at the end of this
presentation so let's get back to the
ancient world what else is distinctive
what's different about the sports of
ancient Greece among the most
electrifying aspects of the ancient
legacy was the early democratization of
sport aristocrats had an edge because
they had the leisure time to train and
the train the money to travel
contests but cash rewards enabled the
small-time athlete the promising athlete
without resources to amass wealth at
lesser contests to afford ultimately a
trainer to compete at the great
festivals Aristotle tells us about a
fishmonger who won the boxing at Olympia
Aristotle says it was unusual but it
happened how different the early years
of our modern Olympics Jim Thorpe
arguably the greatest athlete of the
early part of the 20th century was
stripped of his medals because the
International Olympic Committee found
out that once he had played some
semi-professional baseball the rules
that the Henley Regatta explicitly said
that no tradesmen mechanic or artisan
was allowed to row in that elite
competition
that's why Kelly John Kelly one of the
great oarsmen was told that he could not
compete at Henley he won the Olympics
but the fact that he had once it is said
worked in his youth as a bricklayer was
enough for him to be excluded from the
regatta how different the world of
ancient Greece so let's take a moment to
discard the historical fraud of
amateurism in the ancient Olympics it's
true that at Olympia itself the victor
received only an olive crown but that
was a credit card for an enormous cash
reward as early as 590 BCE the laws of
Solon say that the returning Athenian
victory will get 500 drachma and since 1
drachma was the wage that a artisan a
skilled artisan could expect for a day's
work that was a considerable pot of
money and on top of that came free meals
for life so forget the self-serving
nonsense of Baron Pierre de Coubertin or
Avery Brundage the early leaders of the
Olympic movement designed to keep the
common man out of sport the ancient
Greeks knew better
before the Greeks started Western
civilization on its path to
self-government they were modeling in
their sports the prerequisite concept of
equality of opportunity there's another
one to keep for the essay that some of
you're going to have to write now there
are many explanations for the startling
Greek practice of competing fully naked
other cultures in the ancient world did
not do this the Romans in particular had
nothing but contempt for the Greek
practice and that what is the
explanation I think the simplest one is
the most likely it is the ultimate
leveler of mankind an athlete of vast
wealth might come to Olympia wearing
expensive crimson clothes but there
would be no such marker to signify who
he was when the contest began when he
met naked his naked competitor it was
the most dramatic of equalizers whereas
Casper Whitney who headed the US Olympic
Committee in the early part of the
century found that the thought of
playing sports with a person from what
he called the lower classes to repulsive
to imagine he's very explicit about that
we know without a doubt that the bluest
blood of ancient Greece was shed right
there with a blood of people like the
fishmonger who actually won the contest
at Olympia knowing what we do about
class prejudice throughout history this
is nothing short of electrifying the
Greek democratization of sport at its
earliest stages
so let's now begin to pull the threads
together with few exceptions no
festivals had team events the major
festivals awarded first place
recognition only no runner ups the
official rewards were enormous and
competition ferocious often brutal there
were few attempts made to keep sports
safer and less traumatic all social
classes
that is to say males
could compete in the great games and the
uniforms that they wore were their own
nakedness some years ago I was invited
to participate in a symposium in
Freiburg Germany to address the question
was there a Greek miracle were the
ancient Greeks exceptional I continue to
answer strongly in the affirmative and
that affirmative answer is based in
large part on the unique Greek embrace
of competition of which sport was the
clearest but hardly the only
manifestation and there are great
lessons for us to learn from that today
open an intense competition the Greek
agon yes that's where we get our term
agony is one of the gifts of ancient
Greece to humankind it was the catalyst
of greatness and the same time a
remarkable safety valve for ambitions
that could otherwise destroy the common
focus on which the state's survival
depends the Greek world thrived on
competitions the tragedies and comedies
that you read in Western civilization
classes were all staged competitively
with their authors vying jealously with
one another for the top prize and there
were other contests as you can see from
this slide contests of Potter's contests
of Weaver's contests of physicians could
they identify the instruments they
needed for their trade all staged at
city expense for a population that
strained for personal recognition and
egalitarian as they were they energized
an informed civic life but now a
remarkable contrast when multi ADIZ the
Athenian general who masterminded the
victory over the vast Persian army at
the Battle of Marathon in 490 BCE
if that's not familiar
it's an extraordinary moment Milt IDs
who argue arguably saved Western
civilization asked if the Athenians
would add his name to the great mural
that they painted of this extraordinary
victory and the Athenians
gave him a flat no we won the battle
said the Athenians not the general so
also when the general came on and his
colleagues asked Athens to reward them
with with their victory statues for the
victory they achieved over the Persians
in 476 they were told no this was the
victory of our city-state not you he
will not get personal recognition so you
can see the contrast I'm building up to
we have inscriptions from 2,500 years
ago and sometimes they're surviving
statues of athletes who won at olympia
and sometimes in the other great games
but when the general who saved Western
civilization's wanted to be personally
commemorated he got a flat no from his
city and also there was this odd custom
of ostracism in the political sphere
when somebody was amassing too much
power and influence in Athens no
corruption no misdeeds but just getting
to great that person won the lottery to
leave town for ten years all of this a
great leveling a great containment of
too much self-glorification or assertion
in the crucial worlds of military and
politic political political achievement
so how brilliant was the Greek agon the
Greek athletic agon and other types of
contests riches status and everlasting
Fame accrue to those who refined their
arts whether in the stadium or in the
theatre and since with the notable
exception of Sparta the Greek cities did
not keep standing armies in training
incessantly for war the enthusiasm for
sport kept the male population
physically ready for the
of combat which brings us back I hope
you've had that thought in your minds to
the very curious level of danger and
discomfort that the Greeks structured
into their athletics not accidental but
structured marching and 50 pounds of
armor in the heat of the Greek summer
and then running against the enemy's
line of shields and spirits was a
fearsome task it required great physical
and emotional stamina we find in Greek
athletics as we saw a moment ago no rest
no refreshments no rounds no shade for
the competitors it is exactly the
physical and emotional stress of Greek
warfare so the athletic agon served the
double purpose of indirect military
training and providing an outlet for the
highly competitive and individualistic
impulses of a nation of warriors raised
on the epics of Homer how do we be like
Hector and Achilles we can't in hoplite
warfare the Maverick is as dangerous as
the coward the warrior who jumps out and
breaks that line of shield and says I
can take any one of you guys has just
endangered his whole unit all of his
comrades so just like the shirker who
throws away his shield the hero the
Maverick who tries to act like a Homeric
hero is a danger and threat to the state
so the Greeks had to learn to
subordinate their personal ambitions on
the battlefield and in political life to
the needs of their city-state not
everyone of course could compete at the
great national festivals but certainly
by Hellenistic times there were nearly
300 local festivals spread throughout
the ancient world everybody had a chance
for a moment of personal glory
now given their obsession with honor and
glory it is a remarkable fact this will
be the subject of an address I'm going
to give at Texas Tech a month from now
that the Greeks never used dueling to
settle their private quarrels the
history of Europe is a pretty gruesome
place swords were the less dangerous
weapons that were used here we see
there's Alexander Pushkin dying in a
duel Alexander Hamilton great loss of
course to this nation many great minds
of Europe falling in this senseless
waste of human life but for all of their
desire for honor and recognition our
ancient Greeks do not engage in this
senseless waste of citizen life make no
mistake the value that the Greeks placed
on competition especially athletic
competition is not a cultural Universal
objects opposed here on a quote from
Nietzsche in his less insane days and
one from the socialist thinker Thorstein
Veblen what you can see here is a stark
contrast Nature had it right the
Hellenic popular pedagogy was that every
every human endeavor benefits from
fighting from competition and he has a
nice dig at modern educators he's in the
19th century we have seen it even more
intense but contrast what the socialist
thinker Thorstein Veblen has to say it's
a assertion on the basis of predatory
human nature indispensable to the
competitive individual but not directly
serviceable to the community the Greeks
thought otherwise the worker's paradise
on this theme declared that the Olympics
would quote deflect workers from the
class struggle and train them for the
new imperialist wars the protests
recommended instead labor gymnastics
babblin obviously had it right I always
kind of liked this the relation of
football to physical culture is
same as a bullfight to agriculture No
so let's return to the Greek ethos I've
left a difficult question for the end
the Greeks were not savages they had a
remarkably high regard especially in
Athens for the rights and dignity of
their citizens so much so that in Athens
simple assault could trigger a capital
charge the death penalty against the
perpetrator the rules matter I cherished
this slide from a Panathenaic vase
celebrating the great games held in
Athens every four years it's not an
action scene rather the two young boxers
listened respectfully to the older
referee as the personification of
Olympia looks on that's actually you
can't read the inscription
she's very curious how this Panathenaic
contest will turn out because one of
them may well be at Olympia before long
so here we have an athletic scene that
emphasizes the rules civilization
constraint and yet these boxers boxed
with thongs that would make probably
even the most fanatic fan of mixed
martial arts seem a little queasy the
Greek sports were no anomic free-for-all
what level of risk and trauma however is
acceptable in a civilized society what's
productive for civic life and what is
destructive I think we all draw
inspiration from the brilliance and
courage of an athlete like Lindsey Vonn
2010 in the Alpine ladies skiing
downhill she clearly had a leg injury
she wouldn't let an American physician
look at it because she didn't want
anybody to be questioning her ability to
enter the Olympics and she wins a gold
medal she had a broken finger and she
won the slalom so forgive that recent
feisty fit of temper when she
smashed her skis she felt bad about that
this is an athlete of extraordinary
spirit or one that perhaps has been
forgotten in time which would be sad
shunned Fujimoto from the Montreal
Olympics of 1976 Fujimoto continued to
compete in the team event after breaking
his knee in the floor event he scored
high on the pommel horse and then got
onto the Rings with a broken knee his
team needed his victory in order to
defeat the Soviet Union he did a high
dismount about eight feet above the
ground and lands squarely on his feet
holds it for the regulation second
before crumpling with a shattered leg
beneath him he and his teammates saw the
Rising Sun flag rise as opposed to the
hammer and sickle considering his deeds
considering the deeds of somebody like
Lindsey Vonn who of course the ancient
Greeks would not have allowed to compete
in the great Olympics there was a little
festival for women rather minor
attention that it got their mistake not
to let women compete but let's continue
looking at the ancient world I hear the
voice of Pindar from 2,500 years ago
deeds of prowess without risk window
Fame among mankind but where I ask
that's getting back to the question that
we left some time ago where do we draw
the lines of rules and regulations that
will determine who we are as a society
for the Greeks athletic competition
channeled and refined ambition Hesiod
one of our earliest Greek poets arguably
writing before Homer
Hesiod elevates competition to the
catalyst to the Energizer of society she
spurs on to work even the delicate men
all the same Potter envies Potter and
remember a moment we ago we saw a
contest for Potter's builder Envy's
builder beggar is jealous of beggar and
poet is jealous of poet and of course
the tragedians and the comedian's of
ancient Greece whose works we read were
indeed jealously competed competing
against each other for the Greeks
competition was an end in itself a way
to manifest excellence in an activity
that was a microcosm virtues in the case
of athletics on which the safety and
future of the state depended as modern
Americans slouched towards giving a
trophy to every kid on every soccer team
in every season at the torts setting up
safe spaces for everyone at college and
university to protect them from every
conceivable Buffett of life and as we
turn sadly voyeuristically to watching
professional sport in high luxury we
would embrace much to our benefit the
hellenic spirit of competition
conscience and moral awareness must
guide us to find that balance between
respect for the well-being of athletes
and the instinct that is so vital for
our energetic nation to push to the
outer limits of performance and
achievement the takeaway lesson from
ancient Greece is that the crucible of
competition produces greatness there are
going to be winners and losers but a
competitive society overall is
ultimately a winning Society thank you
we will be brought to you
hello hi so it seems to me that in our
current sports culture there's a very
large focus on hedonism and decadence
impe extravagance of various stars and
whatever field they play and I'm just
wondering what your opinion is on that
and what you think the ancient Greeks
would have to say about that sort of
exaggerated self-congratulation very
profound and important question
the Greeks recognized and feared what
they called hubris arrogance more than
anything else it was a religious affront
and it was an affront to civic life the
law that I referred to earlier that
would punish on even with a death
sentence a person who was guilty of
simple assault was called the Graf a
hoob Reyes the law having to do with
hubris with arrogance the Athenians felt
that somebody who would behave that way
is the sort of person who would set up a
tyranny in the ancient city so we have
an important lesson from antiquity about
who we are as mortals that's reiterated
over and over again the Greeks certainly
did celebra fie they're top athletes
they gave them enormous rewards but as I
said a moment ago the ancient Greeks had
a way of leveling that which was the
democratization of sport something that
we've only learned rather late in the
history of the Olympic movement that by
giving people the opportunity to earn
money that will get them into sport
we're actually opening up the field
I am very troubled by what television by
what the great sports complexes do
because they introduced a level of
voyeurism that takes us away from the
immediacy of the athletic experience and
colleges and universities need to pay
attention to this
when a special Center is built as has
happened at some universities just for
the competitive athletes it sends a
signal that other people's health other
people's competitive instincts don't
matter so I I'm I'm very intent on
seeing schools recognize the need to
have the opportunities for people to go
to the highest possible level but also
to remember that everybody else needs a
shot at it as well we have someone in
the front
why
again an important question when the
dream-team are unbelievable basketball
team entered the Olympics 92 it was the
clear sign that the change had taken
place and to be honest I I'm much less
interested in the dream team than I am
about the runners who were able for the
first time to afford the leisure to
train so they could be at the top level
people are very humble backgrounds that
was a great breakthrough why did we do
it it seems to me very clear that the
real genesis of this was the
professionalization of sport in the East
Bloc that for years had given their
athletes an edge over people from the
free world so in that regard it really
did level the playing field I was glad
of it for two reasons one was of course
that finally you know we had leveled the
playing field but more important than
that the leveling of the playing field
among our own citizens that we achieved
I'm sorry could you say that one more
time do you feel that some of the sports
better embodied than others the virtues
the the theme that you discuss today
about all of the glory and everything
like that an individual 'no sand stuff
like that or all right well let me be
perfectly frank when i heard there was
going to be beach volleyball i thought
oh lord what next
but then when I watched the level of
physical attainment and the skill that
went into it I thought well ok let's
enter the 21st century no to give a
simple answer on I was a college
wrestler I as a midlife-crisis got up to
second down
status in Taekwondo I've always loved
individual martial arts but the
experience of striving to be the best in
something really can transcend any
particular activity and here I go beyond
sport as well on the the competitive
edge that we can see whether it's in the
Tchaikovsky music competition or in the
Olympics is a very very valuable thing
in my throw away sarcasm which is based
on what I observed in my daughter's
soccer team is the antithesis of that
it's really good for people to be able
to be recognized for outstanding
achievement not simply for being there
being there is good I mean it's being
encouraged but we're taking away the
opportunity for the recognition of the
extraordinary effort of pushing beyond
the frontiers somebody who does a great
job on a team is doing a great job is
capturing that competitive spirit the
fact that I was always a maverick
doesn't mean anything and the fact that
the Greeks had so structured their
competition is not something that
necessarily has to transcend time into
the into the modern world there's a lot
to be learned from the team effort but I
do like at the core of it the ability of
the individual to stand there alone and
for the ancient city-state going back to
the legacy of Homer this was absolutely
crucial this was a safety valve for
people who would otherwise have had the
most explosive dangerous instincts
thank you for your talk you mentioned
chronic traumatic encephalopathy and as
a as a neurosurgeon and the father of a
college football player I have an
interest in that the the pathologist and
the neurosurgeon that described this the
pathologist actually thinks that high
school kid shouldn't play football no
contact and that you shouldn't have
Little League football and so forth but
on the other hand Julian Bailes the
neurosurgeon he has been president of
Pop Warner little they football for
years he played football and asked him
the question you know having described
this and done brain cutting and looked
at it would you let your son play
college football and he didn't hesitate
he said absolutely because the character
that it builds is greater than the risk
and I just wondered if you might comment
on what you think because this is
something now that has taken over the
sports news is it's crying and we know
it's a problem but there's the benefit
outweigh the risk again a profound
question that we we really do have to
face squarely and struggle with on the
basis of good data well I'll go back to
Pindar deeds of prowess deeds of skill
without risk window honor among mankind
I I think the operative question is how
contingent is it and how likely is it
I've had more professional experience
looking at boxing and there what bothers
me is the great gap between amateur
rules and professional rules on they
almost certainty that after a certain
amount of time if the rounds go on too
long that there's going to be lasting
damage and that becomes a question
really of the regulation of the sport
not as Sweden did to ban it but
being able to look squarely at the event
and say well okay enough this is a
mismatch one of these guys is getting
badly injured it's over now a TV crowd
doesn't like that the people who paid a
lot of money for the tickets won't
necessarily like that but it's the right
thing to do and with chronic traumatic
encephalopathy I would just like to make
sure that we've got some really good
ways of screening quickly on the least
hint of brain injury the least hint of
disorientation take a rest even if
you're valuable to the team we've got to
get more concerned that way
or else we are really crossing important
lines no crowd watching a boxing match
should have been happy at seeing what
went on between ray Mancini and Koo Kim
that match should have been stopped many
rounds before the subdural hemorrhage
became so bad and mix in mixed martial
arts we're seeing this too often where a
match is allowed to go on too long so
that's my kind of complex maybe not
totally satisfying answer I would not
like to see these opportunities for
people to demonstrate skill and bravery
taken away but on the other hand I don't
want to see a society that becomes
cavalier about their safety
this is a terrible sense of difference
between boxing in which the is to
deliver blunt-force trauma to your
opponent and football or even you know
we have collisions in baseball and
basketball in which it's it's more or
less anted incidental to the intent of
the sport yeah a fair question
what's contingent and what's going to be
structured into the into the activity
itself I certainly would never want to
see bucks and go back to the Greek
method of using last sort of thongs and
what I would like to see more of is
referees that are really Ricky
recognizing that their future depends on
stopping bouts more aggressive ring
physicians one doesn't tend to see the
kind of damage done to people who stop
at the amateur level of boxing because
it's structured so much differently and
it can be very very interesting very
exciting to watch with football I think
really we have to yield to the experts
on what level of contact is going to be
reasonably safe recognizing that any
kind of endeavor like that it's going to
have some contingent damage there's no
sport even a non-contact sport like
basketball where that kind of thing is
not going to happen and so it is a
calculated risk but the calculation
ought to be based on a very firm grasp
of what is safe and humane for the
people competing not to leave people in
a situation where they're going to be
paying a price for the rest of their
lives and lives that may be very short
I thank you for your talk I've really
enjoyed it um so what then do you think
of the Greeks you said we see death in
sports as a tragic accident
and do you admire their do you just
admire their spirit and how much they
valued the honor of dying in sports or
do you think that they devalue with life
just what is your comment on that
well I've kind of tossed that one around
for a great number of years yes I think
the Greeks were downright extraordinary
it's also a very important thing to make
a judgement like that in terms of its
historical context we don't have the
experience of seeing armies come up to
our cities knowing that if we lose the
battle there's some likelihood that
every man in the city will be killed and
all the women and children taken off
into slavery which was something that
did happen in the action world we've
read about it in facilities we don't
have the legacy that the Greeks did of a
ambitious and unsettled warrior elite so
in that regard I am actually pretty
comfortable in not being judgemental
about the ancient Greeks would I
encourage it in modern times no I have a
great deal of difficulty accepting the
way modern professional boxing is
designed for the voyeurs rather than for
the safety of the competitors I really
quite admire boxers and I don't like the
idea that they're dooming themselves
either to a quick death or a slow death
from Parkinson's or some other kind of
brain disorder but getting back to the
the ancient Greeks it is a different
world that we have to look at and we
have to be able to appreciate the genius
of being able to deflect the potential
disruption
of a volatile elite into these
activities I did it did draw a brief
contrast with dueling in Europe in 19th
century Germany there were some
calculations about 8,000 sword fights
that were held in colleges and no no
tips were put on the the weapons the the
idea was that it would be a great thing
to have a scar across your face as Miss
to show off to everybody that you were
brave and then the graduates would move
onto pistols and these were good pistols
these were rifled ones so they were
pretty accurate at fairly close range
I think the Greek experience was a far
more socially beneficial experience if
one has to choose so that's that's a
cultural judgment that I would come to
with the rise of modern technology in
science the ease for which individuals
can train to Olympic a professional
level has become quote/unquote easier
what do you think the next 20 or 30
years will look like as we begin to see
a higher turnover rate among athletes in
professional sports if I understand your
question you're pointing to the the fact
that our techniques of training of
biomechanics of nutrition have gotten so
much better that we're going to see
achievements that make our old records
look rather feeble you know the the
four-minute mile used to be a pretty
extraordinary thing and now you know
that's not I still think it's pretty
extraordinary but on that's not
something that it's going to win you a
an Olympic crown on you know distances
in the in the in the long jump high jump
on these are not drug dependent
achievements these are achievements
based on more careful training more
scientific training this is wonderful
this is really what
achievement is about pushing ourselves
through our skill and our knowledge and
the knowledge of trainers medical
knowledge - more and more achievement so
I have no real quarrel with that and I
will say the Greeks had no quarrel with
that they all had professional trainers
if they could afford them and that was
what often spelled the difference
between the winning athlete and the the
one who would not be able to achieve we
have time for one more question do you
think there will ever be a time when
doping will become the norm in order to
advance the spectacled nature of
professional sports
I certainly hope not
and what I hope is that the technology
of detecting that and disqualifying
athletes who indulge in that will will
actually get better and better this is a
let me go back to that slide of the
referee admonishing the two athletes
before the Panathenaic contest the rules
matter it's one thing to compete with
absolute intensity maybe even with a
disregard for your own safety like
Lindsey Vonn or Sean Fujimoto but
cheating is a grotesque violation of the
norms of society and whatever spirit
takes place and so you know in athletics
where we're trying to concentrate on the
contest and the ability and skill of the
contestants that is one of the most
egregious and one of the most effective
ways to sabotage what sport is supposed
to be teaching us this seminar is about
sport and character so the answer to
that question is I certainly hope not I
don't think so
I think we still recognize that this is
one of the last activities
in our society that tends to be so
averse to recognizing achievement this
is one of the last activities where we
really do try to cultivate a meritocracy
and if that goes we have lost something
of extraordinary value I hope that never
happens
thank you